♪ ♪ ♪
- L'arrondissement de Rivière-
des-Prairies-Pointe-aux-Trembles
est un immense territoire
éloigné du coeur de Montréal.
Situé complètement à l'est
de l'île, certains disent ici
qu'à l'heure de pointe, il est
parfois moins long se rendre
à Trois-Rivières
qu'au centre-ville.
- Est-ce que j'ajoute un peu
de terre pour le solidifier?
- On se sentait d'ailleurs
bien loin de la Ville
ce matin-là. La mairesse
sortante, Caroline Bourgeois,
plantait des arbres sur l'île
Ste-Thérèse, face à
Pointe-aux-Trembles.
L'arrondissement souhaite y
créer un parc récréotouristique
en collaboration avec le
gouvernement et la Ville
de Varennes, de l'autre côté
du fleuve.
CAROLINE BOURGEOIS, candidate
mairie de RDP/PAT, Projet Mtl
- On parle 5,4 km carré environ
d'une île qui est à proximité,
là, on la voit de chez nous et
c'est toujours dans cette idée
de pouvoir mettre en valeur
nos espaces naturels.
- L'engagement cadre bien
avec la grande priorité
de Projet Montréal
pour l'arrondissement : embellir
le milieu de vie.
- C'est un parc linéaire
sur 4,25 km.
- Caroline Bourgeois nous
a montré la transformation
d'une ancienne voie ferrée
en sentiers pour les piétons
et les cyclistes.
- Souvent, on associait
la pointe de l'île,
notre arrondissement, on parlait
des raffineries, on parlait :
"C'est loin, c'est gris."
Puis moi, c'est tout le
contraire. Ce qu'on nous parle
maintenant, c'est justement
de ces projets verts qui mettent
en valeur les lieux.
- Dans le nouveau parc,
nous croisons cette électrice,
contente de la transformation,
mais qui ne sait pas encore
pour qui voter.
- La mairesse de
l'arrondissement semble vouloir
s'occuper beaucoup de
Pointe-aux-Trembles. C'est juste
la mairesse de Montréal,
qui est plutôt centre-ville,
je trouve. Elle est plutôt...
Elle est beaucoup pistes
cyclables.
- Cet argument, on l'entend
souvent; dans un arrondissement
où le style de vie est plus
proche du 450 que du Plateau,
où tout est plus axé sur l'auto
que sur le vélo.
- Êtes-vous satisfaite
de l'administration Plante
dans les dernières années?
- Non!
- Pourquoi?
- Trop de pistes cyclables.
Ici, à Pointe-aux-Trembles,
il y a des places qu'il y a même
pas de trottoirs! Mais il y a
des pistes cyclables.
- Moi, je suis du côté
de Valérie Plante.
- Pourquoi?
- Pourquoi? Parce que je trouve
qu'elle a apporté un vent
de changement à la mairie
de Montréal. Je dis pas que
ça a été parfait, là, il y a eu
peut-être un peu trop de pistes
cyclables peut-être, là!
LYNE LAPERRIÈRE, candidate
mairie RDP/PAT, Ensemble Mtl
- Il faut nécessairement
aménager la piste à un meilleur
endroit pour que ce soit
sécuritaire.
- Lyne Laperrière, la candidate
pour le parti de Denis Coderre,
a choisi, quant à elle, de nous
amener sur le boulevard Gouin,
là où les deux voies
de circulation ont été réduites
à une seule et où les camions
de livraison barrent
parfois la route.
- Les pistes cyclables, c'est
un irritant pour la majorité
de la population, pas seulement
au centre-ville, mais également
ici, dans notre arrondissement.
On veut pas simplement
les éliminer, il faut simplement
les sécuriser tout d'abord,
puis ensuite harmoniser
pour que les déplacements
soient plus fluides.
L'embellissement, c'est bien,
mais il faut aller aussi
aux besoins essentiels des gens
au niveau des infrastructures.
- Dans l'est de l'île, l'enjeu
de la mobilité va bien au-delà
du débat sur les pistes
cyclables.
- Parce qu'on est les oubliés.
- Le transport, c'est horrible!
- Le transport là, il est pas
mal.. déficient, là.
- Juste en termes
d'investissements, je regarde
par exemple à Rivière-des-
Prairies en réfection routière,
on a refait le boulevard Gouin,
on a refait Perras,
Maurice-Duplessis
et Henri-Bourassa.
- Si elle est réélue,
Caroline Bourgeois tentera
de convaincre la Caisse de dépôt
d'ajouter quelques stations
au REM de l'est.
- Il faut absolument.
Si on appelle REM de l'est,
il faut que Rivière-des-Prairies
soit inclus!
On va avoir votre appui
aux prochaines élections?
- Ouais
- Oui?
- Lyne Laperrière est d'accord.
Elle promet aussi d'ajouter
des autobus.
- Il faut nécessairement
augmenter la fréquence
pour répondre aux besoins,
faire une distance de quelques
kilomètres, ça peut prendre
40 minutes dans notre
même arrondissement.
- Et elle veut plus de bateaux
vers le centre-ville.
- Les navettes, on peut pas
s'en passer. On est privilégiés;
on est entourés d'eau,
c'est un projet qui a fonctionné
quand même depuis plusieurs
étés. On veut augmenter
cette fréquentation-là.
(sirène)
- L'autre enjeu important,
c'est la sécurité.
Dans le nord-ouest
de l'arrondissement, les coups
de feu sont désormais fréquents
en raison des conflits
entre gangs de rues.
Je me trouve dans un quartier
de Rivière-des-Prairies qui est
calme, qui est familial,
assez bien nanti. Il n'y a rien
qui indique qu'on est dans un
des secteurs les plus chauds
de toute la Ville de Montréal
et pourtant, c'est le cas.
Depuis quelques mois,
les fusillades se multiplient
dans les environs. En septembre,
juste ici où je me trouve,
à cette intersection,
une douzaine de coups de feu
ont été tirés en plein jour.
D'ailleurs, la victime est allée
se réfugier dans la maison que
vous voyez derrière. La porte
est encore barricadée.
- Deux fusillades qui sont
arrivées à côté de chez nous,
puis moi, j'ai deux chiens
puis même, j'ai un pitbull
puis j'ai peur, personnellement,
de marcher le soir
avec mes chiens.
- Je ne sais pas comment régler
ça, mais c'est rendu
que c'est... On a peur,
on a peur ici.
- Plus de sécurité, sinon moi,
je déménage.
- À entendre les solutions
proposées, on pourrait presque
croire que Caroline Bourgeois
et Lyne Laperrière sont
dans le même parti.
- On a une augmentation
du nombre de policiers qui sont
présents sur le territoire,
mais c'est aussi que la réponse
n'est pas que policière.
Il faut travailler aussi
avec les groupes communautaires
comme on le fait déjà,
d'embauche, bien sûr,
de travailleurs de rue.
- On va nécessairement augmenter
les effectifs des corps
policiers. Pour nous, c'est
important. On doit mettre
l'accent sur la surveillance,
les interventions, financer
davantage les OBNL, travailler
avec eux pour financer
leur mission.
- Dans Rivière-des-Prairies-
Pointe-aux-Trembles
comme ailleurs à Montréal,
les promesses de Projet Montréal
et d'Ensemble Montréal
sont souvent similaires.